qui n'a jamais eu peur de se mettre en
danger
arias provocateur france nouvelle
zélande
c'est la femme d'un il revient pas lui
la jalousie
face à cette situation d'angoissé qui
est l'inconnu elle arrive à se créer un
bonheur par rapport à cette situation
assure inventer un monde intérieur qui
la sauve de la souffrance qui est là qu
est la disparition sans explication par
le qui a genre qu'est ce que tu crois tu
pas parce qu'ils voyagent et travaille
beaucoup avec les bus soient
raisonnables je te demande juste de
faire attention de gt pour c'est trop
ces deux livres moindre frais donc les
choses c'était un tdp de moi j'en fais
pas je pense que l'aspiration pour un
personnage comme marie dans ce film
vient de la vie uniquement ça ne vient
pas d'eux du jeu ça on ne peut pas faire
avec les émotions comme ça il faut
reconnaître ses émotions en soi donc de
son propre vécu un jeu bizarre je
voulais que le spectateur soit son
charme de charlotte et qu'on l'est mais
aussi bien pour les moments où elle est
effectivement très belle et des moments
où elle est plus des nuits où les prix
des fèves ça me semblait important parce
que dans la vie on n'est pas toujours
sublime et ces deux aspects me semblait
me semblait essentiel pour la
compréhension du personnage et aussi
pour l'attachement aux personnages